well now to the nfl and what a season
for the raiders just imagine for just a
second
if it had been a normal year think of
the crowds electricity the fun
just this season alone players that have
rolled into las vegas and played against
the raiders
some of the best quarterbacks drew brees
came into vegas so did josh allen
raiders have played against patrick
mahomes twice and the goat tom brady
came to vegas
raiders matt ryan on the road and now
this week
how about phillip rivers oh what a
collection and just the first season of
raider football here in las vegas
and the cults roll in on sunday as the
raiders make a post season push
they'll need the services of everybody
what's it's huge it's good
it's huge with any sport you watch the
lakers win their playoff this year they
you saw lebron james and anthony davis
play you know you take uh
any team that's in the world series or
any team that's uh winning
uh in post-season play i don't remember
the 49ers win without montana
and their their arsenal you know the
chiefs won it last year they were they
were
seeing their best players play their
best football in the biggest moments
and we've been missing a lot of players
the last two decembers
and right now we're missing a lot of
players and it's a concern
but we're going to get ready for the
next game no matter who's available and
i'm really proud of our players and
coaches
all right sunday's game with the colts
will be broadcast right here on cbs your
network home for the las vegas raiders
1pm kickoff